what does it mean for you to be going
into the premiere of halo a game that
you started working on
the like i guess very early on in the
process like you're the voice of cortana
from day one
it's overwhelming it is exciting and
overwhelming and to see this happen and
come to fruition is a dream there's no
way to have known when you you know
first voiced cortana what it would
what it would lead to yeah was there a
moment in your life where you look back
on that day you're like well that was it
that's like if that's all i ever do
that's
that's pretty good
i'm trying to remember what i had for
breakfast that day
and what my you know what my morning
routine was because i want to repeat
that
right yeah it was the lucky day that was
a good day um
what are the fans of the of the series
going to
uh going to like about the show that you
guys have put together fans of the game
yeah fans of the gaming series yeah and
i guess the books and also the other
stuff and the whole lexicon of halo all
the lore we incorporate a lot of the
lore
um and i
i feel like we try to remain as true as
possible
while exploring different avenues a
different timeline a different story so
i i think that fans are really going to
appreciate this and at the same time
hopefully pave the way for people who
maybe don't play video games
who just like a good sci-fi story
what was your reaction when you first
saw pablo and i guess the other men and
women in their spartan armor live you
mean
like in person i
it was well pablo's
enormous
so i think my first response was oh oh
we found we found it we got it this it's
so beautiful it's so right on it was
exciting yeah
you